hi everyone and welcome to another video
on how to use chess comm in today's
video we're gonna be discussing how the
new settings and Flipboard features are
universal to every board and platform
you see on the new chess comm here in
the live chat Selena as Fabiana Caruana
just won a very nice game against
grandmaster Wei Yi we see that we can
adjust the settings by scrolling over
the resize board button which I've
already showed in many of the other
tutorials and now the flip board and
settings button magically appear why do
we have them only appear if you scroll
over the resize board button that's
actually by designed so that if you're
in a blitz or bullet game or even in a
daily chess game you don't accidentally
click on your settings or flip board
these magical invisible little figurines
only show up when you scroll your mouse
over the resize board and once again we
see them appear allowing us to flip the
board and pull up the settings specific
to that platform that's important
because if I click on the settings here
not only can I adjust the board design
and everything that I would do in life
chess but it brings up all of my live
chess specific settings enabling pre
moves Auto clean promotion etc then when
you're on the main site whether that be
daily chess once again we see that I
scroll my mouse over and I can now flip
the board as well as pull up the
settings or in tactics trainer which is
also the same thing I I scroll my mouse
over and now I can flip the board and
pull up the settings the main site that
would be daily chess tactics trainer
opening studies just about anything you
might see that involves a board under
the learn menu is the same platform so
that you can browse and use the same
board style whatever you might want that
to be here we see it's blue and if I go
into my daily chess game and refresh
you'll see that my board will now be
blue so the main sights features both
daily chess tactics and like I said
other learn tools that have a board are
all universal allowing you to change to
the style you like with just one click
and the live chess features remain on
their own platform but the universal
tools are found once again by scrolling
your mouse over the resized board button
and then choosing either Flipboard or
settings as your heart desires thanks
for watching